هشام حتى نستمع اليك بشكل جيد دعني انوي
لهذا الخبر العاجل نقلا عن اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي اذا بدء مهاجمه اهداف تابعه
لحماس في غزه يبدو ان عمليه الرد
الاسرائيلي المتوقعه قد بدات بالفعل نقلا
عن اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي التي اكدت بدء
مهاجمه اهداف تابعه لحماس في غزه كان
مراسلنا قبل قليل يتحدث عن ما نقلته
فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي اكدت انها
جاهزه للرد وهي مستعدا للمواجهه اذا
المواجهه كانت مرتقبه لان التهديد بالرد
الاسرائيلي كان واضحا وجرى الحديث عنها
خلال ساعات
الماضيه مراسلنا هشام زقوط تحدث عن سماع
ذوي انفجارين اثنين في مدينه غزه
ونقلا عن القناه الثالثه عشر الاسرائيليات
اذا الجيش يوجه ضربات لمواقع تابعه لحركه
حماس في